all right Scott we got a chance to check
out battle born it's a MOBA kinda I mean
it definitely takes ideas from robots
but I would hesitate to actually label
it a MOBA 2k calls any hero shooter but
maybe we'll just settle on mo best yeah
I go from 0 best that's it yeah accurate
the mode that we want to talk about is
the PvP mode meltdown which people
who've previously played monday night
combat and other mobile type games know
this mode where basically you escort
your minions to a muncher and it bunches
them and you get lots of points yeah and
obviously you want to sabotage the other
team by killing their little minions and
protect your own minions that's the
whole so there's almost like a tower
defense aspect to it too because you
gained currency and by turrets and
upgrading your own characters along the
way obviously so what makes battleborn
kind of unique is that there's actually
25 heroes in here now went back and
actually looked up in Borderlands by the
time Borderlands was said and done there
were about 16 characters so this
launches with 25 characters each of
these characters is pretty unique like
you really need to have a sense of
situational awareness in this game know
who you are and who you're fighting
against I mean I think what's really
interesting about battle born is a lot
of games that encourage teamwork you can
still run off on your own and have a
good time like in Call of Duty or
something like that you can run off and
you have a gun and it plays the same in
battle born because the characters are
so different some of them are almost not
even fun to play unless you're sort of
using them the right way with with the
other complementary characters that sort
of working with them yeah so a good
matchup that I really liked was Phoebe
versa rendi if I'm probably killing that
name but basically arandis a hit-and-run
character she's got four arms she goes
in really fast she does damage she can
drop this thing called shadow fire
pillar which does a lot of damage but
then she has to leave she has an ability
that lets her leave which is basically a
backwards leap that drops damage as she
gets out so for example when she runs
into Phoebe who basically has a saber
and who can teleport in it's this really
cool match between somebody who deals
damage and wants to stay on another
character and somebody who deals damage
and wants to escape from another
character yeah that's actually really
interesting things that as you play you
kind of learn which matchups are more
favorable for your character
because sometimes you'll be playing this
particular character and come across
somebody else playing a character that
really out matches your specific
abilities and you kind of need to learn
that in certain cases you're better off
or treating and getting help from your
teammates because your skills just put
you at a disadvantage against certain
other characters so in terms of overall
look and feel I was still definitely
getting that borderlands vibe from this
game oh definitely it definitely has
that similar cel-shaded style but also
the tongue-in-cheek writing is very
similar so I think people who are fans
of borderlands will feel very
comfortable in battle born definitely I
mean yeah in addition to playing some
pvp we got a chance to play through a
full campaign mission and there was a
lot of banter back and forth between
like a mini boss and the final boss they
were just sort of bickering over the
comm system the entire mission it was a
lot of fun it was the same kind of humor
you would expect from Borderlands I'm
Arrakis the spider king of all spiders
no not today okay you're not a spider
king you're an s-1 century unit and your
name is Jack
it's pretty clear that this is a gearbox
game this was you know worked on by
members of the borderlands team like
that flavor is still in there and really
that's that's what it comes down to in
battle bore and that's what they've been
pushing since day one it's all of these
different characters and all the
experiences you can have I mean they
release that trailer recently that
detailed like the innumerable number of
combinations and skill trees that you
can use just all the different ways to
play that's really what battleborn comes
down to and that was even more apparent
in PvP and it has been any other time we
played the game for more coverage of
battle born stay tuned to gamespot com
halfway there our minion all times
you